- Let's talk about "Teen Wolf: The Movie."
So does it pick up wherever
the series left off?
- No, it doesn't actually.
So the series, it's 15
years after the series.
- Okay.
- Which is wild
because my character was
always younger than Tyler.
- Yeah.
- I was always playing younger
and now my character's older
than Tyler by like three years.
- Yeah.
- Or two years
or something like that, so, no,
it's a completely different world.
My character has moved
away from Beacon Hills
which is like where
the town is in our show
and he's in Los Angeles trying
to step out of the hero-ship role.
- Yeah.
- Which he was the hero
and like the leader of
the pack back in the day.
Now he's kind of trying to live life
as like a normal human, but
it doesn't work out so well.
- I do think that's really cool though,
when you take time in between
'cause then you have more
story to like uncover
from what's been happening in between.
I think that's really clever.
- It is cool, yeah.
One of our characters has
a son, a 15 year old boy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which is-
- That happens,
all of a sudden people grow
up and you're like, "I'm old."
(Tyler laughs)
Yeah.
No, that's crazy.
That's cool that all the lives are, like,
completely different.
- Yeah.
- I heard that you almost
played another wolf, right?
- I did, yeah.
I was up against Taylor Lautner,
it was between he and I
for Jacob in "Twilight."
- That's huge!
- It would've been huge
but I was really young.
I was like 16.
I wasn't ready for the type
of attention that he got.
- Yeah.
- You know,
so I had to wait a couple more years
and then-
- That's smart
'cause it is a lot of attention.
- It was a lot.
He got a lot at that age
and I commend him for it
but I don't know if I
was fully ready for it
which I owe the me not getting it,
you know?
- Yeah.